ruina y destrucción la vida de los
residentes de san andrés y providencia
cambió cuando los huracanes y otras
jetta arrasaron con todo a su paso las
opciones para quienes se quedan no son
muchas
pasar la noche bajo carpas distribuidas
por el gobierno
hospedarse con algún vecino que no haya
perdido su casa o permanecer a la
intemperie
una parte mañana vemos otra pero estoy
tratando de armar una carpa con
idiomas
a rescatarme pero yo no me quiero ir yo
no me podía mover mi esposo me jalaba y
yo no podía quedé totalmente y no sabía
qué hacer cuando mire
y la brisa en la ráfaga de la risa
levanto la casa completa y empezó a
volar hasta tanque de gas voló hasta el
otro lado otro de los grandes afectados
fue honduras el gobierno ha dispuesto
refugios para los damnificados pero el
espacio se hace pequeño para todos
aquellos que quedaron sin hogar muchos
han tenido que dormir bajo los puentes o
en campamentos informales están llenos
de gente que no está comiendo aquí tan
siquiera siente el mismo pueblo que debe
dejar comida que a la gente el
presidente hondureño anunció el inicio
de una operación de limpieza de miles de
toneladas de lodo y escombros
yota y eta dejaron igualmente miles de
damnificados en nicaragua cerca de 160
mil personas llegaron a estas refugiadas
en 250 centros de albergue pero poco a
poco han regresado a sus barrios en la
medida de lo posible la cruz roja estima
que cerca de 42 millones de personas se
vieron afectadas por el paso de yota y
dieta en honduras nicaragua guatemala y
el salvador